merci je m'installe je ne vais pas vous
parler de déconfinement vrai qu'on parle
de confinement un peu non pas non non
pas de moi si j'ai un seul truc à dire
sur le premier confinement moi je vais
bien vécue parce que grâce à dieu j'ai
eu un heureux événement les amis pendant
que je souhaite romain à tous les mecs
qui sont assorties ce moment le moins
une fois dans leur vie c'est magique
c'est incroyable j'ai divorcé
j'ai divorcé au bout de 20 ans d'amour
et de captivité et à ma libération je me
suis rendu compte d'un truc c'est la
dernière fois que j'ai dragué l'immeuble
c'était en 2001 tu rigoles jean marine
et je te paye en feront bon dernier
rendez-vous alors j'ai perdu tous les
codes la première main que j'ai dragué
dit salut miss m dure dix plus ça c'est
fini est il quand tu restes on pense à
moi tu passes par cette petite période
un peu tu sais ouais ouais chien de la
casse un peu je baise tout ce qui bouge
moi je vous dis à l'époque j'avais qu'un
seul critère c'est est vivante faut le
savoir
j'ai des inscrits sur tous les sites de
rencontres j'ai même une fiche sur le
bon coin est sympa de sang ça et j'ai
sur teen d'heure et je match avec une
fille pour la ramena les maisons j'ai
fait le truc à l'ancienne vous qu'à vous
connaissez bien la maison
je t'aimais bien on avait un dvd truc de
pervers et koutat vient la maison
commencent à se mélanger patins qu'alain
juin en guadeloupe parcours fléché
nombre d'églises ont dû voir un sketch
llc mort et moi chaque valeur n'en
fermer en toboggan comme ça commence à
faire l'amour elle est sur moi je suis
au rythme de croisière je pense à ma
grand mère la guerre je gagne du temps
normal tu vois les députés paul et de
nos secrets et commence à faire l'amour
je sais pas si vous connaissez ce genre
de fille qui dans la vie sont très
calmes et au lycée des furies connaissez
ou pas ouais moi je connaissais pas je
suis un mec de 2001 gmac l'ancienne en
train de faire l'amour à être anglais
regardent et m'a dit maintenant c'est
qui qui tu baises écoute moi bien j'ai
replacé le vouvoiement shebab où madame
apparemment 20000 gym mais mon père et
ma jamais tu avais comme ça à ma décès
qui m'a plu chez moi je crois à mon avis
mais de ses 20 ans d'amour ham a quand
même offert le plus beau cadeau qu'on
puisse offrir un homme va faire une
petite fille ça c'est cool
ouais
ma fille c'est ma vie ma vie à la mafia
l'a7 en allant terminale et c'est pas
évident d'être papa célibataire et
d'être comédien je vous le dis parce que
pendant que je joue devant vous mafia
temps l'extérieur dans la voiture et ça
s'est passé
alors voilà sept ans et a commencé à
dire des trucs incroyables maintenant tu
vas vraiment a commencé à parler elle a
des déficits et petits réflexes de meuf
ya pas longtemps à rentrer à la maison
et m'a dit la phrase que je craignais le
plus depuis que ma fille est née je vous
dis la vérité allait rentrer à la maison
et m'a dit papa j'ai un amoureux à une
franchement ça m'a piqué mais j'ai pas
faire le père ignorant je sais ce qui va
se passer plus tard je sais que ça à
partir en je sais y'a pas ses doigts
d'être est dégueulasse je vous le dit
aussi
mais sa passe est de trois ce qui m'a
fait mal c'est la phrase qu'a subie hier
elle m'a dit papa et j'ai un amoureux et
demain on va faire l'amour chez quoi je
vais bien là la [ __ ] de tara bien là
il s'appelle comment le gosse m10
s'appelle patrick je fais ça c'est le
prof et aucun goal qui s'appelle patrick
jamais tu as dit patauge dans la rue un
enfant qui s'est retournée on est bien
d'accord et je vais le lendemain à
l'école je sors c'est qu'ils patrick je
connais pas tous les gosses tu vois et
je vais le lendemain à l'école est
patrick et c'est un chinois alors il n'y
a pas de vins et je vous le dis comme ça
il n'y a pas de vanne est ce parce que
j'adore c'est un gamin hyper intelligent
pour me représenter très mignon il parle
cinq langues
cinq langues et limbe anglais impeccable
il a un anglais impeccable tous les
matins morning vous dites moi je suis
maire d'anglet je passe va être comme
moi ici sur cette fable mais moi j'ai
appris l'anglais grâce au film bordeaux
je regarde en vo c'est un délire je sais
qu'à force de regarder des films pornos
en vo je replace des phrases de films
pornos dans des discussions
des fois ça parle entre amis et en amont
pour y achever hier à la quête avec la
voix de l'acteur et c'est ma fille je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé dernièrement
avec patrick mais je crois qu'il lui a
brisé le coeur
je perds ma fille rentre à la maison et
me dit papa tu c'est patrick qui veut
plus être marié avec moi et franchement
ça m'a touché j'essaye de creuser je dis
pourquoi patrick avait pu être michael
n'est pas ce que patrick il a dit que
j'étais pas d'elle
et franchement ça m'a touché jeudi près
de la vie samedi parce que maintenant il
va être marié avec carmen parce que
carmen avait plus belle que moi et
carmen à la des chaussures brillantes et
franchement ça m'a touché pied le
lendemain j'ai failli envoyer ma fille
en brillance total avec de l'aluminium
au tour je vois mais j'ai choisi la
pédagogie des filles vous me dîtes si
j'ai bien expliqué à ma fille ok je
regarde ma fille dans les yeux equity
coûte ma fille le plus important dans la
vie c'est parce qu'on a c'est ce qu'on
est ça le plus important c'est bien dit
ou pas ouais je suis dit carmen carmen
c'est une [ __ ]
et j'ai été convoquée le lendemain à
l'école parce que ma fille très
intelligente elle est partie voir
karmann l oedipe appel a dit est une
[ __ ] écoute et non mais j'essaye
d'éduquer au mieux ma fille et c'est que
moi je suis un papa je donne beaucoup à
ma fille franchement je la gatte
énormément sur un manche là tu donnes
plein de trucs et ya pas longtemps me
dit papa c'était son adversaire me dit
papa je veux un lapin et moi je suis pas
fan des animaux je vous dis la vérité je
suis vraiment pas fan des animaux et je
me dis ok tu veux un lapin on va les
chercher un à penly malice mais tu vois
c'est sous sa responsabilité
j'achète tout ce qu'il faut mais tu
t'occupes du lapin est bloqué et on va
animale y chercher un large façade est
déjà parti animalistes pour acheter un
animal pour votre enfant mais si vous y
allez faites moi plaisir regardez le
regard de l'animal
il sait qu'il est plus heureux là bas
que chez l'enfant mafia la pause et
c'est demain le lapin nous a regardés
est fait prendre le hamster on a pris le
lapin de la ramener à la maison
pompon l'a appelé ma fille le lapin elle
lui a mis la misère
elle n'a pas un sujet à la maison le
lapin c'était guantanamo chez moi etc
etc moi jouer ma fille s'occupait du
lapin et je vois qu'à limiter la misère
et je me dis non c'est sous sa
responsabilité je m'en occupe pas échec
à force de voir ma fille met le la
misère au lapin je crois que j'ai
développé une aptitude je comprenais le
lapin jure je comprenais et à chaque
fois que je passais devant la chambre le
lapin - en fait ouais je suis là par
mois et pourquoi j'ai une robe de
princesse
écoute je me suis dit ah tellement lui a
mis la misère le lapin je vais le
trouver en boule avec une clope sous la
douce assure je repassais dans la
chambre la peine regardé fait frais et
pourquoi j'ai un ego dans le cul ya un
problème ou est-ce que c'est pas ma
fille c'est que son lapin il est mort
deux fois et deux fois je partage c'est
le même lapin de la même couleur de la
mer tu vois c'est le dernier lapin
pompon de alors lui-même a regardé mange
moi c'est pas évident d'être papa
célibataire d'avoir un enfant je sais
pas de faire l'apologie du père seul je
vous le dis des fois c'est compliqué
d'arriver fasse que tu maîtrises
pectoraux fonction williams arrivé une
phase avec ma fille a pas longtemps avec
ma fille est là-bas dormir vers 19h30
20h tu vois le truc de bons pères et
jean vers 23h30 je suis tout seul dans
mon cerveau je me dis tiens tarik
mettons un film d'horreur tout seul dans
le noir dans mon salon je sais pas si
vous êtes comme moi ici mais pour moi
les pires films d'horreur c'est les
films d'horreur avec des enfants à
l'intérieur c'est l'europe a dit la
vérité
ouais c'est l'enfant elle est pâle il a
des cernes il chante seul
gossé pas normal mais je suis dans mon
salon je monte en pression avec le film
et j'entends venir de la chambre de ma
fille je me dit attends je vais pas tout
de suite j'attends que la pression
redescend des 30e papa je me dis je vais
je prends ma batte de base-ball normal
et je rentre dans la chambre de ma fille
j'ai eu ma fille et les deux bouts au
milieu de la pièce comme ça je les
regarde j'écoute ce soir c'est où toi ou
moi je mets un coup dans le tibia par
respect je me suis dit on va monter dans
un coin corbeille de maman sus des
pythons ampère ouais bon bah ça j'étais
au courant des sens on sent le poids de
la pensée inventaire dans cette vague
voilà j'ai fini en fait
[Applaudissements]